[Music]
one only has to say the word English
they come running like sick black dogs
at low tide captain I heard about your
selfless heroics with the Iroquois and
via tragedy with the priests well I
suppose there's nothing more than nails
be said on the subject silence will
suffice then good day might I have a
word attend perhaps the kitchen is best
of course I wish to make your property
go on I should like to make use of your
stable serve in excess of barrels trade
having slowed due to the recent unrest
and prepared to pay your hands may you
can store them free of charge no I
insist on pain yes a few coins but that
is not the only reason you are here it
is oh and it is a shame because there is
a greater deal to be made
besides storing a few barrels in my
state
for some coins brownie or four would
refuse to entertain a great indie he'll
go on reminded anything you wish to
restore your standing in this town am i
right
I shall recover my good name barrels and
trade do not remove the stain of your
English name before those times are gone
you overstepped mr. Cook
only a stubborn man would walk upon a
frozen lake when the sun is shining we
can't help each other how is that I
believe Delphine has caught your eye I
don't know what you're talking about
no mr. cook I have seen it with my own
eyes there is no shame in looking upon
her beauty it is there for all to see
nothing it would be prudent for you to
make a match with her and in return you
will help me expand the in Mathilda I
came here merely to store excess barrels
and if you agree to my terms
you will leave with a french voice
alright then we shall agree the storage
of the barrels think on it if you must
but you will come to the same place
[Music]
you